hello fashionistas it is time for a tea
style feed this is the Grammys Edition
and I cannot wait to get into all the
high-fashion the flawless beauty so much
more but you know what I am NOT doing
this alone I am joined by an amazing
panel of guests today I have Trixie
Mattel s square Lawrence and Brett Alan
Nelson here on my couch you guys I'm so
excited to have you thanks for being
here today we are gonna get right into
it because it is 2020 who even says
best-dressed anymore what is Best
Dressed really even mean right so we
wanted to give each of our favorite
looks its own custom Ward so these are
our style superlatives
all right we're kicking it off with the
ultimate timeless goddess Liz oh let's
take a look at what she wore on the red
carpet giving us Marilyn Monroe vibes
[Applause]
I loved this so much yes I wasn't
feeling like Marilyn Monroe vibes but
you know also like just classic
Hollywood movie star she was really
giving us like a full star moment
yeah it's spot on and I mean the work
that was behind this dress I saw the
inside of it it was insane all the
boning the work that Versace put behind
it and even the little Erte inspired fur
it was super magical it definitely will
live on this look Brett is on Liz's
styling team and she was wearing Attili
a Versace so Brett is gonna give us
literally every single detail about what
it was like to be with Liz Oh last night
at the Grammys it was I mean this was
her night it's everything it was Liz's
Grammy night and from the carpet looks
that she did to the opening of the
performance it was all so magical the
skin she looks gorgeous she looks so
flawless let's actually talk a little
bit about her performance because she
opened the show blew me away
I mean I was not like I was expecting
anything less I I just love her but you
know a performance look is so much
especially when you need to do the quick
changes like she did so tell me about
this dress this is Kristin Ariana yeah I
was custom Christian Siriano and I was
super inspired by like an operatic
ballgown and she was the conductor of
this group of beautiful women
I wanted it to spark like a galaxy
there's a lot of glitter on stage and
there were little dots of just sparkle
all over the whole entire dress now how
long did you have to put the slip
together
sadly I had like a week you're kidding
me yeah it was a really quick turnaround
how do we yeah so everyone involved like
Christian turning this dress out I mean
late night sewing this thing off for
another look so that must have taken a
lot of rehearsal in practice as well we
only had three times and it was a it was
a bit of a stress the the camera block
that we did because the zipper busted
and it was kind of rushed to figure it
out cuz you can't mess up it's the drama
the drama that's seven now a lot now
back to her red carpet look for one
second a lot of people were making this
comparison from obviously Marilyn Monroe
but Brittany Spears in the year 2000 was
wearing a similar vibe gay people need a
half reason to reference Britney Spears
white dresses what was Britney wearing
Versace too though you know what that is
a great question
we will find that it's fine though but
that's the thing I love about fashion
that you know ten years ago it's dated
20 years ago it's new again
right it's Michigan that bodice is so
beautiful because you know like listen
I'm like a size 16 and I know that when
you're doing that kind of corseting the
bell has to be the right shape so you
don't get things pushed up and out
mm-hmm her body I agree and as a curvy a
woman just seeing someone taking up
space like that like that ball gown it
was a moment and I just want every curvy
woman to know that she can do anything
when she sees this Ashley I've got that
well I think that was their whole thing
to it Lizza likes to feel sexy and
sometimes people don't know how to dress
a bigger girl and they just want to put
them in oversized dresses that's not the
way she wants to look right it's not the
way we want to see her either because
she's so body-positive
look I know sexy [ __ ] yeah it's like
cover up hide it or and it's like no no
we want to celebrate these bodies we
don't have speaking of seeing her body
she took off that Christian Siriano gone
on stage revealing a much more body
conscious look which was awesome it was
like this cool one-piece Brett tell us
about that it's by this croatian
designer named Sigmund and it was it was
a very different look
the day before the performance he wanted
to add a lot of ruffles and movement to
it but we ended up cutting off every
single one of the ruffles this huh no
yes
we completely crystal did Swarovski came
on board as a sponsor with it so the
whole entire performance had I think
like 250 thousand crystals onstage very
low-key you know we switched into that
in like less than 48 seconds which was
super super fun
now she changed again in the audience
this beautiful silver fringe gown it was
just dripping she looks so stunning oh
that alone that was Marco but that was
another Versace moment that they did and
it just you know they killed it and they
obviously they dressed little nas to
who's in that photo with Elizabeth the
look has big Bob Mackie energy 100 it's
it dripped with her and there's other
photos of her to where it looks just
from the waist down she's completely
naked and you see her beautiful legs
Oh a little clear heel it was pretty
damn good it's such a night Bravo fret
for your work yeah three out of her
eight awards last night so she had she
had quite an action so somebody else who
really gave us some drama on that carpet
miss Ariana Grande
wow she had a lot of dress she had a lot
of dress and this was custom Jean
Bautista Valley and I just have to say I
loved the Opera Lankes gloves mm-hmm I
love a moment of drama I was waiting for
her to give us a moment of drama she did
and not just one but multiple what's a
drama she's so petite I'm like is that
dress huge or she just doesn't
yeah is that a normal size dress yeah
she's just little yeah I better kick it
I'm gonna deal with the dress I was
watching them steam that backstage and
there was like three guys just like
doing this a nice little wrist trick in
all the little curves it was wow it was
huge
so it was actually on my gown I could
have had like 20 of me mm looks so good
don't it kind of is reminiscent of what
she was supposed to wear to the Grammys
last year yes she heard that did not
pose in that she didn't wear didn't I'm
not going I thought something very
similar
my dryer just yesterday wasn't still
that big no it didn't look as good as
this I don't want to dress that big and
it is super uncomfortable as well the
fact that she sat like the hose oh my
gosh yes sitting sitting down like she
planned this you have to exact long you
have to walk and kick yeah yes yeah
and she didn't just wear this look she
changed and came back on the carpet gave
us a second look this was a two-piece
shopper Ellie look she said it she
actually told Vogue that she couldn't
decide she had two very special custom
looks made couldn't decide so she walked
the carpet in both all right guys if you
had to pick I mean only Ariana ganda is
gonna walk the carpet and to look and
they're so both beautiful I prefer the
Schiaparelli gown to be honest I think
there's something super pretty and
different about it maybe maybe the
uniqueness I wish she hadn't worn the
sleeve and bottom boat yeah maybe she
didn't get her nails done I'm serious
she probably got whispering grubman
probably well let's take a look at her
in the audience because she did make a
choice I guess she went back to you if
you're sitting next to her right she's
not maybe there's a toilet underneath
the dress needed a plus-one couldn't get
it in there under that let's take a look
at the Jonas Brothers on the carpet cuz
they always wear a nice coordinator
giving them the smartest suits award for
their smart suits they were wearing
wearing Sonya they're all so handsome
and it felt so easy it didn't feel like
too too much I don't know they just felt
very natural I think they look great
there's a broken yes super straight guy
this is so above and beyond are you as a
straight guy straight guy going to a
carpet this is like 10 out of 10 they
made an effort they brought a t-shirt
and sneakers you know exactly they
coordinate really well again we're
coordinating you know what this is the
thing I thought in the b-roll when we're
actually seeing them on the carpet it
looked a little dull and brown but when
I saw the photos I was like oh that's
photographing like a really nice bronzy
gold I've the
the photos released sold this for me at
first I was like oh they're in some
brown suits and we call that court now
we don't look matchy-matchy
yeah yeah matchy matchy and Priyanka
looked beautiful as well in her long
fringe number but this was one of those
things we were like you know some people
loved it some people were on the fence
it looks a little nightgown to me I mean
she looks beautiful she can do no wrong
but I loved the fringe I wasn't I
thought I didn't think it was doing a
ton yeah for her I feel like I don't
know what's going on just under the
belly button here what's the little
badge situation she's wearing Ralph
Andrew so straight off the runway all
right and then stealing the runway
completely Billy Porter
he loves to steal runways and he did it
again so we're giving him most mean
worthy because immediately after this we
saw at least four different names
aha East and a hat by Sarah so how do
they even do that it must be controlled
somewhere someone's pulling something
right this is what I need to know these
are the important questions we need
answered wouldn't you hate if you were
the one in control and your friend was
just like you Senora yeah here we go
action that hat yes it's amazing this is
the thing
so Grammys it's Billy Porter yeah I'm
gonna be extra extra and he said yes I'm
gonna be extra his stylist Sam Ratelle
has been really pushing all the
boundaries with the red carpet this was
the Hat maker Sarah Sokol working on
this beautiful custom hat it's so
different for Baha'is too they do such
like relaxed very yeah and this is a
total disconnect at that tool I do like
it I have to say that it's a little
Michaels hey listen and we love it I'm
sorry you have to say what it is and
frankly I don't think that's enough
in the body like that's ten even readout
over in there like right we need to do
that 250 Sourav ski sponsor thank you he
could have went to listen be like I just
had 600 but I love the knee down the
same the knee down his pool and it moved
so nice on stage when he went on stage -
it did it's the thing about fringe it's
so beautiful alright last but not least
miss Shania Twain get on her the ageless
wonder award or literally looking
completely ageless and gorgeous she is
wearing a custom Christian star
Christian Siriano mm-hmm and I know it's
so much I'm actually I was really happy
with this because we've seen her out in
the public a little bit more as of
lately because of the Vegas residency
and a few of the choices have been a
little questionable but this she's so
iconic I mean so beautiful it's so
simple it's sexy but it's fresh with the
little short yes and then she has that
belt detail which just isn't it's so
iconic for her I feel like it ties in
like everything that she stands for and
it's fun too and I'm loving that she did
a high pony like it looks like old but
still age-appropriate somehow we love
the little Pomeranian pony for sure yeah
[Laughter]
he likes to play a little game before
award shows where we play stylist and
then guess what we think people might
wear and we actually guessed that this
gown would show up on the Grammys red
carpet let me show you guys where who we
thought would wear it oh yeah Ariana
Grande would wear it and adores so
excited to see someone wore it and that
she did the ponytail so you guys were
almost there we were almost there I
haven't seen Ariana's Lex for years
though they're always in like I haven't
seen them so a rare sighting we're like
are you on the siding and the host of
the night Alicia Keys gave us so many
looks right ad me speechless we're
having her the breathtaking bombshell
award for that snatched waist this is
another person yeah you can see that's
Versace from a million miles away I know
can you tell well it's the corset tree
it's the chain mail it's so I
connick but I mean the work that they do
and obviously they dress
numerous people like their Atelier must
have been slammed slammed so many looks
that we haven't even talked about yet
but also first on we haven't you know
she keys in makeup in a long time yes
right and two sparkles but she's too
perfect I was happy about those two
sparkles too and those were our et style
feed style superlatives for the Grammys
so we all know that a look is never
complete without the glam so we're
taking a moment to take a closer look at
the best beats of the night see what I
did there
Grammy a days talking beats guys so
we're actually gonna kick it off with a
few cool things we saw people do with
their nails last night I loved the
attention to detail that so many stars
put on their whole look so let's start
with Billy Eilish because she was givin
us a lot
I don't just all the way into the nails
it's just have you ever been the Grinch
and also nominated for an award and also
going to tag the wall with spray paint
and also our robber
I mean she's 17 years old and she loves
the all-over Gucci print the nails are
all over Gucci she she's always the
humor there's a total sense of humor
there but the nails you have to do the
detail every waking at every single
centimeter of you it's cool she looks
cool that's the thing like she's one of
those artists that owns her personal
styles so hard that you you almost can't
fault her for it but yeah it's a lot
look I love it as well because I know
that all of her fans being like young
girls will be able to do the nail look
they can't afford full Gucci outfit but
they can be like listen I need this
you're buying now so I think that this
is gonna start render that's a really
good point yeah I also have an I like
that she didn't do a claw cuz lately she
has been doing a cloth that's she the
crochet but this feels cool I don't what
do you call that I wear where now where
nails okay her nails are so purposefully
tacky
yes we don't we like this is not a
finger shape you know
it adds to our little Grinch moment - Oh
totally
she's like child Grinch I want to be her
friend another great nail moment last
night was Liz oh yes
we got claps for those nails she they
were so elegantly extra mm-hmm the best
way I can explain she had a white nail
and this little sparkly jewels see the
dress and then the dripping Commack
little drips look at this yes her nail
artist is the coolest girl ever and they
when they prep looks they put so much
time behind it and there's mood boards
and there's ideas when she was putting
these nails on it's so special and
there's so many great shots I mean it's
so good and her hands are moist hands
yeah it's a part for a woman like this
exact skin tone to wear white and not
get makeup anywhere so yeah I love those
little tips you're so true so true
alright so speaking of makeup Alicia
Keys is not one that we usually think of
about makeup but last night I was
pleasantly surprised to see that she did
a nice combination of her no makeup vibe
that she likes to stick to and just
enough for the Grammys she had a little
sparkle in the eye a little sparkle
around her edges I was really into this
I love that and I hope no one drags her
for putting makeup on again
obviously it's super subtle and natural
still but you know I think when you
commit to something like that it's
always scary to then go back in case
people are like you said you were never
gonna wear makeup again or accessory and
it's like no listen some days you know
we just want to feel a little bit glam
and this is the Grammys I'm with her if
I ever want to put makeup on again also
though it is very hashtag brave but also
if you look like Alicia Keys you can you
can make a lot where I know you were
great her skin is beautiful and she's
clearly wearing very little on the skin
because you see her skin yes you see the
skin texture you also see that she's not
kind of filled with a lot of fillers and
like I just think it's so beautiful and
fortunately kind of radical now to
really embrace that natural beauty that
she is she clearly has and she changed
many times throughout the night as host
usually do but she kept the glam the
same throughout the night which I loved
because
you know she's got a lot to do as the
host now someone who went in the
complete opposite direction
Nikita Dragon who we love so Nikita had
this really cool illusion dress on with
the pearl detailing and the pearl
detailing goes all the way up onto her
face her makeup artist glam tech Steven
T had all of these jewels actually
attached to her face which I thought was
really cool and different there's a
great shot of it right there it's such
an intentional whole look you know when
someone really thinks from head to toe
and so I think that that was executed
really well it's like she had a white
head and just ran with it oh my god and
also Nikita is a makeup artist so
obviously even he knows even if her
makeup artist cancelled she's gonna look
perfect yeah that's true
he's so pretty I mean it's subdued him
at all I was really into this all right
so guys moving right along if you have
been watching style feed you know we
never kill a trend without a proper
style debate so for the Grammys we're
gonna take a moment to discuss some key
looks from the carpet and here's what
we're gonna do - more prom oh my god I
have more cups so everybody gets one of
these paddles so I'm gonna present a
look and we're gonna decide if we love
it we're free we don't know if we're not
that into it there's no right or wrong
answer let's jump right in okay grip do
a Lipa first look go off the deep trend
so this the thing I love this look I
love her I love her style she has a very
particular point of view she's kind of
rocking this like early 2000s vibe which
sometimes makes me cringe II I liked her
from the neck down
I wasn't into the hair and makeup so for
that I'm gonna give it up oh yeah I
loved the hair I thought it whole
statement it's such a weighing moment -
I feel like he made the look I she's
wearing you're like there's a whole
moment I kind of wish she would've had a
pencil Bravo like gone all the way oh
wow that's just a commitment that's such
a commitment I agree I this is so plain
doing to me mama this - camisole reject
look from the movie jawbreaker clips in
a slip mama no
but but you're right if she had
committed to the full period finis yeah
I think it would be more successful mmm
like the thinner brow and that you know
and the whole thing all right what do we
think in general everybody votes
I like okay we're split we're split
we're so late that's fair fair all right
next up fka twigs who always does a
thing she always has a look oh so you
know I didn't expect anything less from
her she's wearing a Ed Marlar who's
who's done a lot of looks for mm-hmm
I feel like she looks like she's gonna
cast a spell on everybody totally did I
was just blown away I was blown away
blown away I did not know I don't know a
lot about her I didn't I always did she
could dance like that
I'd heard this that she had skills but
that was just I was like goodness next
level skill but making me how it think
about it to make it but let's vote
thoughts no oh my I love a theatrical
yeah doing both Phantom of the Opera
fantasy yeah yeah okay uh it was a lot
it was long she has a beautiful face and
it did try that look was so much I
wasn't looking at her face there's so
many other things to look at it the way
she's acting them as the hood I liked it
though I loved it a portion of like
these bigger shoulders t little ways I
mean come on women all right next up
Tyler the Creator these are all the
creative people on the carpet Tyler the
Creator showing up in a chic hotel
bellhop outfit with luggage what's in
the bag he shows us what's in the bag it
is literally the clothes he changed into
that be accepted his award in I maybe
thought yeah I that I did not like it
and now the story of it now I like it
just because it's their prop he used it
but was he accepting the win he's like
look I have my clothes you know this
made me giggle I know that I'm gonna
give it I love it because I love that he
changed into what he had I love that it
was pink it just it made me smile who
made the look that is a good question
good question doctor
I was trying to read what it's dangling
the legs she was a pink hat yes I was
doing the same okay guys
boats boats oh I'm kind of torn but I
love I just love the concept I love that
there was so much thought behind and we
love the playfulness yes
see I love when people have fun on the
carpet you have speaking of having fun
on the carpet let's take a look at lil
nas X tells everyone thinks it's so good
oh my god it's beautiful yeah so fun I
love that he was like guess what I'm gay
five seconds I don't know how yeah I'm
gonna plumb new depths of game is he's
got a harness he's got scarfs he's got
hot panda boy I think it's so cool cuz
they took so many elements of what
Versace is so classic for from the belts
to the scarves to the leather to the
pharaonic yeah yeah and it's like it's
the perfect mix of what him as a real
gay fashion icon should be wearing wait
are those boots connectors does their
you know it looks like they are but they
totally are get it oh my yeah I love the
earring too it's like an 80s classic
clip on earring you know first say I
love it they should really do a line
together
I don't know insane to the line they
should really get together and do
something cuz that would be now should
we even vote I think everybody knows
we're all standing at look and he won
two Grammys last night you know an
excellent night alright last but not
least BTS BTS now I'm just gonna full
disclosure I saw them and I was like
they look like an ad campaign whatever
they're selling I wanted I love a
minimal vibe they have glossy skin and
glossy hair and they look so chic and I
loved it but they're on the list because
a lot of people disagree
[Laughter]
they better reveal two completely nude
bodies or something right
mama feels like extras in Harry Potter
the funny thing to me is a chic though
it is very sheep of BTS everything that
we've seen a member at this point has
been so loud and big
maybe this is like oh we're gonna pull
it back for the Grammys and their
performance was a bit crazy but I can't
decide if I love it or hate it I'm not
into it
it's a yawn for me oh I'm alone on this
thing come on you can just be a vote but
that yeah that could be a vote you can't
decide I loved it I want the new
turtleneck and all the leather pieces I
want to wear it to work tomorrow
exactly but as a group as a group it's a
great day what I'm good it would have
been kind of major if we had a little
like violet chachki reveal where
whimpers you know yes nobody ever does a
purposely bad look that reveals
something amazing I would like no more
of that
right like troll the system a little bit
you guys and just like that we are done
with the 2020 ran it off a very big
thank you to our Grammy style squad
Trixie Mattel it's more Lawrence and
Bret Allen Nelson thank you guys so much
being here this was super fun and guys
don't forget we have new episodes of
style feed every Wednesday at 3:00 p.m.
so we will see you guys then
[Music]